[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في حصاد الليله معكم
حسن
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل
البدايه من الخرطوم وهذا المشهد من
العاصمه السودانيه التي شهدت اليوم
اشتباكات وصفت بالاعناف منذ اندلاع
المعارك قبل 20 يوما
والى واشنطن تحديدا البيت الابيض والذي
صدر منه بيان يمهد الطريق لعقوبات امريكيه
جديده مرتبطه بالصراع في السودان
والى رام الله وتصعيد اسرائيلي في الضفه
الغربيه احدث حلقاته اغتيال ثلاثه من
الشبان الفلسطينيين في البلدات القديمه من
مدينه نابلس
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
في اليوم العشرين للاشتباكات بالسودان بيض
يقول ان المعارك يجب ان تنتهي ويوقع
مرسوما يمهد لفرض عقوبات محتمله على
المسؤولين عن تهديد الاستقرار بالسودان
ومديره الاستخبارات الوطنيه الامريكيه
ترجح ان يطول القتال وان تمتد تداعياته
الى المنطقه
وفي تطورات الميدان اشتباكات وصفت بالاعنف
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في
محيط القصر الرئاسي بالخرطوم الجيش يشن
غارات مكثفه على محيط القصر الجمهوري
ومواجهات عنيفه في مدينه الاوبيض غربيه
سوداء
[موسيقى]
بعد يوم من الهجوم على الكرمل
[تصفيق]
هجوم جوي روسي يستهدف
والجيش الاوكراني يقول ان دفاعاته اسقطته
سياره في سماء العاصمه واخرى في دينيبرو
انفجارات ضخمه تهز خيرسون وهجوم روسي واسع
النطاق على مقاطعات الجنوب بعشرات
المسيرات
في احدث حلقات التصعيد الاسرائيلي قوات
الاحتلال تقتحم مدينه نابلس وتقتل
فلسطينيين قالت انهما نفذه عمليه بالاغوار
الشهر الماضي
كتائب القسام تتبنى العمليه باثر رجعي
وتعتبرها ردا على الاعتداءات في الاقصى
وجنود الاحتلال يقتلون فتاه فلسطينيه في
بلده حواره بزعم قيامها بعمليه الطعام
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه
ناقشنا السياق وخلفيه اعلان احمد نجيب
الشاب رئيس جبهه الخلاص الوطني في تونس
انه تلقى اخطارا من قد التحقيق بمثوله
امام القضاء الى جانب عدد من المحامين
وثلا وعشرين شخصيه سيتم التحقيق معها
بتهمه التامر على امن الدوله لاستطلاع
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي في اي سياق تاتي احدث
حلقات الملاحقه القضائيه للمحامين وصفصيات
السياسيه والاعلاميه في تونس وجاءت
الاجابات على النحو التاليه
20% قالوا ان سياق يتعلق بضلوع الناشطين
والسياسيين في انتهاكات امنيه بينما اعتبر
80% ان ما يحدث هو ملاحقه من قبل السلطات
التونسيه للمعارضه ورموزها هذا السؤال
سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم
دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار
الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
بحسب وسائل اعلام الاسرائيليه تحقيق لسلاح
الجو الاسرائيلي يكشف خللا في تفعيل
منظومه القبه الحديديه في جوله القتال
الاخيره في قطاع غزه
في اليوم العشرين من الاحداث الجاريه في
السودان تشتد المواجهات المسلحه والازمه
الانسانيه ايضا مع اعلان برنامج الغذاء
العالمي ان منتجات غذائيه مخصصه للمحتاجين
في السودان تقدر قيمتها بما يتراوح بين 13
الى 14 مليون دولار قد نهبت منذ اندلاع
المواجهات لكن ثمه التطور لافت واشنطن على
خط الازمه وبقوه فقد اعلن الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن ان المعارك الدائره منذ اسابيع
في السودان يجب ان تنتهي مهددا بعقوبات
جديده على الجهات المسؤوله عن اراقه
الدماء
ترد ان طرفي الصراع وفق على تمديد الهدنه
من الرابع الى الحادي عشر من مايو الجاري
ليس هكذا تكون الاستجابه لمقترح ايجاد
بين القول والفعل منذ السبت الذي سيذكره
السودانيون بمراره وحده هذا المشهد الذي
لا يتغير فهل سيغير بيان اخر للرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن شيئا ام سيلقى نفس مصير
البيانات السابقه الداعيه الى وقف
الاقتتال والعوده الى ما قبل الخامس عشر
من ابريل الماضي بينوا هذه المره يمهد
لخطوه قد لا تتاخر اذ اعلن امرا تنفيذيا
جديدا يسمح بفرض عقوبات تحمل الافراد
المسؤوليه عن تهديد السلام والامن
والاستقرار في السودان وقال ان العنف
الدائره هناك ماساه وخيانه للمطالب
الواضحه للشعب السوداني بحكومه مدنيه
وانتقال الى الديمقراطيه اشار الى ان
الحكومه الامريكيه مستعده لدعم الجهود
الانسانيه المختلفه في السودان عندما تسمح
الاوضاع الميدانيه بتقديم المساعدات ما
نجحت فيه الولايات المتحده وغيرها من
الدول والمن الدوليه والاقليميه منذ بدايه
الازمه هو اشلاء الرعايه من هناك حديث
الضغوط من اجل وقف دائم لاطلاق النار
والوساطات لانهاء التناحر والفوضى التي
تتمدد وتتوسع تبدو بلا امل في حدوث اختراق
وشيك كان الجميع استسلم للسيناريو الاسوا
قالتها صراحه مديره الاستخبارات الوطنيه
الامريكيه الصراع قد يطول
تقديرنا ان القتال في السودان بين القوات
المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع من
المحتمل ان يستمر لان كلا الجانبين
يعتقدان ان بامكانهم الانتصار عسكريا وان
لديهما القليل من الحوافز للجلوس الى
طاوله المفاوضات يسعى كلا الجانبين الى
مصادر خارجيه للدعم وهذا الامر في حال نجح
فمن المرجح ان يزيد من حده الصراع ويخلق
احت اكبر لانتشار التحديات في المنطقه قبل
لها بيوم سمع ايضا اعتراف للامين العام
للامم المتحده انطونيو كوتيريش يزيد من
قسمه الصوره الجاليه للحاله السودانيه
تحدث عن الاخفاق في منع اندلاع الحرب التي
فاجات الامم المتحده على حد قوله في
القاهره اوضح مبعوث الجنرال البرهان ان
الجيش قبل بمبادره الهدنه السعوديه
الامريكيه وليس وساطه لحل النزاع لا يعرف
هل سينتهي على بدء الاجتماع الطارئ لوزراء
الخارجيه العرب الاحد المقبل في العاصمه
المصريه لبحث ملف السودان الساخن جدا
لدرجه ان نيرانه قد تحرق دول المنطقه اي
افاق للجهود الدبلوماسيه العقيمه حتى الان
هذا هو الافق الوحيد المؤكد منذ 20 يوما
مع كل دقيقه اضافيه من الحرب يموت اناس او
يرمون في الش وارع ويزداد تفكك الدوله
الكلام لوزير سوداني مدنيا سابق
قال مناسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي جون كاربي ان الامر
التنفيذيه الذي اصدره الرئيس جو بايدن
بشان السودان يفوض وزاره الخزانه وسلطات
المعنيه بحث الاجراءات المناسبه في حال
قررت الاداره وفرض عقوبات على اشخاص في
السودان
سيكون امرا ممتازا بالفعل الا تكون هناك
حاجه الى فرض عقوبات لكنني لا افسر الامر
التنفيذي بانه تحذير وقد ذكرت بوضوح اننا
ندعو الطرفين الى وقف القتال والعوده الى
الطاوله لبحث عمليه الانتقال الى سلطه
بقياده مدنيه وهو الامر الذي يريده الشعب
السوداني
من البيت الابيض معنا مراسله الجزيره وقفي
اذا وجد
هل علمت طبيعه هذه العقوبات او الاشخاص
الذين يمكن ان
تستهدفهم العقوبات الامريكيه بشان السودان
حسن بدايه كما اوضح جونبي حتى اللحظه لم
يتم اتخاذ فرض هذه العقوبات فعليا
ضد
الجنرالاين
حميتي والبرهان يعني
سمى تحديدا البرهان وحميتي على انهما هما
المتسببين في
حاله الاوضاع التي تدور الان في السودان
هذا ما قاله جون كيربي واكد حتى الان لم
يتم اتخاذ هذا القرار ولكن بموجب
الصلاحيات التي منحها اليوم الرئيس بايدن
في قراره فاصبح لدى الاداره الامريكيه
وزاره الخزانه والجهات المعنيه
بفرض هذه العقوبات على كل من يتسبب
بتدهور الاوضاع في السودان
وبالاشتباكات المسلحه الدائره حاليا ومن
يساندهم ايضا بحسب جون كيربي
هذه خطوه تمهيديه في حال قررت الاداره
مستقبلا بفرض هذه العقوبات وقال ان الشيء
الذي سوف يمنع الاداره من فرض هذه
العقوبات هو فقط في حال وقف الاقتتال ونزع
السلاح واكد بانه اذا كان الجنرالان بحسب
وصفه جادين في تلبيه تطلعات الشعب
السوداني فينبغي عليهما نزع السلاح هذه
العبارات الذي
ظهر اليوم في الاحاطه الصحفيه اليوميه
البيت الايبادليوضح ما جاء في قرارات
الرئيس بايدن وتصريحاته او بياناته
الصحفيه اليوم كيربي اكد ان المطلوب
امريكيا هو وقف دائم لاطلاق النار نزع
السلاح وقف الاقتتال وكذلك الانتقال الى
سلطه مدنيه تتلبي تطلعات الشعب السوداني
وايضا الى العمليات وقراطيه حسب في مراسله
الجزيره من البيت الابيض شكرا جزيلا لك
نفى وكيل وزاره الخارجيه السودانيه دفع
الله الحاج علي وجود اي حاجه
لمبادرات وساطه تهدف لحل الازمه في بلاده
واكد دفع الله في تصريحات خاصه للجزيره في
اديس ابابا بمستهل جوله في دول الايجاد
اكد ان الحكومه السودانيه قادره على حل
الخلافات الداخليه على حد تعبيره
نحن كما ذكرنا ونؤكد ان هذا النزاع النزاع
الداخلي
نحن لا نرى ان هنالك حاجه لاي من اي جهه
في هذا الوقت لن تتقدم لمبادره خاصه
ببساطه وحل
للنزاع الحكومه السودانيه قادره على ان
تضع له حدا قريبا ان شاء الله
ودعوه كيلو وزاره الخارجيه السودانيه دفع
الله الحاج علي في تصريحاته الخاصه
للجزيره دعا دول جوار السودان للتضامن مع
الحكومه والجيش السوداني مشددا على ان عدم
استقرار السودان سيؤثر على الاقليم
ان السودان هو دوله مهمه
من ناحيه جيوسياسيه
اهميته
للاقليم
واذا حدث فيه لا قدر الله
اي عدم استقرار سيؤثر على كل الاقليم
ويتعدى الاقليم ولذلك اناشد كل الدول ان
تساعد في ان تحافظ على السودان واستقرار
السودان
ينضم الينا من مدينه
بوجمبوره في بوروندي بين ضوء وزير خارجيه
جنوب السودان السيده الوزير مرحبا بك كان
هناك اتصال
اجراه رئيس جنوب السودان مع كل من البرهان
واحميتي عما اسفر وهل هناك مبادره واضحه
من دوله جنوب السودان
شكرا جزيلا اولا وانا هنا في مدينه
بوجمبوره
للتوسط في قضيه مع الكونغو
السعاده الرئيسه فخامه الرئيس سيلفا في
بدا محاولاتهم في الثاني من مايو واترى
اتصالاته مع الجنرال البرهان
والجنرال حميتي وهذا ما اريد ان اتحدث
اليكم حوله اليوم
ما هو فحوى هذا الاتصال
وماذا اسفر
هذه المحادثات
كان هناك اتفاق مبدئي من جانبي كلا
الطرفين الجنرال البرهان اتفقا على ان
هدنه تبدا اليوم
وتستمر حتى الحادي عشر من الجدران الحمضتي
ايضا قبل من حيث المبدا هذا العرض وارسل
رسالتين منفصلتين
وايضا
ان يكون هناك هدنه من سبعه ايام اليوم هو
البدايه اليوم اليوم الاول لهذه الهده من
سبعه ايام
وايضا في الخرطوم اليوم
وفي اماكن اخرى
تم خرق هذه الهدنه وهذا اثار قلقا بالغا
لدى فخامه الرئيس البكاء يعني الهدنه التي
اقترح
في الحقيقه بدات هدنه اليوم
وكان لدينا قلق
وفخامه الرئيس الفاكر
بسبب قلقه اتصل
برئيس الجمهوريه جزر القمر وايضا قاده ابن
الاتحاد الافريقي لبحث حاله الهدنه
الحاليه في السودان
طيب وماذا وما هي النتيجه يعني هدنه من
سبعه ايام لم تحترم
وايضا هناك اتصالات يقوم بها الرئيس
الباكر ايضا حتى الان لم تنعكس على الارض
في شيء ماذا ايضا
سيقوم الرئيس
الجنوب السوداني
لهذا السبب فخامه الرئيس اليوم اتصل
بالرئيس البرهان مساء هذا اليوم
ليعرض عن قلقه
عن عن عدم احترامي الهدنه اليوم وايضا
فخامه الرئيس ايضا حاول الاتصال هاتفيا
بحمدتي لكن الاتصال لم يتم لعدم التمكن من
اتمام الاتصال هاتفيا لكنه اتصل بالرئيس
البرهان واعرض عن قلقي عن خلق الهدنه
لا ادري ان كنت قد تبعت ما قاله وكيل
وزاره الخارجيه السودانيه بان بلاده ليست
بحاجه لمبادرات وساطه هل جنوب السودان
معني بهذا الكلام
في الحقيقه نحن نتدخل بناء على دعوه من
الايجاد ومن السودانيين انفسهم من الرئيس
البرهان
وايضا من قائد القوات الدعم السريع حمدتي
وهناك اتفاق على ان الحل يجب ان يكون بين
السودانيين انفسهم
هل لديكم الان يعني
تقول انه جرى اتصال هذا المساء مع
البرهان لكن لم يتم التمكن
باتذكر مع حماتي هل لديكم مبادره جديده هل
سيطرح شيئا جديدا الرئيس سيلفا كار بتكليف
من الايجاد
انها ليست مبادره جديده
لهذا السبب الرئيس سيلفا اتصل باستمرار
رئيس الاتحاد الافريقي
والفخامه الرئيس سلفا بحث معه بشكل مطول
وضعيه وقف اطلاق النار
واهميه تمثيل الحكومه السودانيه
والقاده الدعم السريع لكي يكون هناك
محاولات لوضع حظ لهذه الحرب المستمره منذ
ثلاثه اسابيع وكان هناك تاكيد على اهميه
الاتحاد الافريقي
والايجاد وطبعا الافارقه يعتبرون ان
المشكلات يجب ان تتم على ايدي الافارقه
انفسهم لهذا السبب الرئيس سيلفا بحث مع
الرئيسي الاتحاد الافريقي هذه القضيه طيب
هل ابلغتم بان الطرفين سيرسلان
مبعوثين الى او ممثلين الى جنوب السودان
من اجل المحادثات هذا الامر كان مطروح
سابقا هل ابلغتهم به رسميا
اليوم الرئيس البرهان
واخبر السفير سلفا بان مبعوثا خاصا
سياتي يوم الاحد
وسوف ينقل الرساله
ونحن نامل بانه بعد الانتهاء من تلك
الزياره سيكون هناك
مبعوث خاطئه الى جوبا يوم الاحد ايضا
فقط يعني
البرهان سيرسل مبعوثا يحمل رساله لكن ليس
هناك في المقابل مبعوث منح ماتي من اجل
الالتقاء في جنوب السودان للتفاوض
نحن نعمل ان يوم الاحد مازال بعد ثلاثه
ايام من الان وان
تبادل الرسائل من الرئيس سيلفا الى برهان
وحميدتي
ستؤدي الى استجابه من من جانبيهما ويستغل
فرصه هذه الايام الثلاثه ليبعثان بمبعوثين
الينا من مدينه بوجمبوره في بوروندي بين
الضوء وزير خارجيه جنوب السودان شكرا
جزيلا لك
وايضا معنا من واشنطن اسير ديفيد شان
مساعد وزير الخارجيه السابق لشؤون افريقيا
سيد ديفيد اود ان اسالك عن موضوع العقوبات
التي فوضت وزاره الخزانه بشانها يفهم من
حيث المبدا انها اذا ما اتخذ قرار بهذا
الموضوع ستكون عقوبات ماليه على البرهان
واحميتي ان لم يستجيبا لوقت اطلاق النار
وللتفاوض
الرئيس بعيدا اليوم
قرر باصدار قرار
تنفيذيه وهو يضم خمسه صفحات وهو يضم
تفاصيل كثيره حول اقرار عقوبات محتمله حول
اي شخص اجنبيه يتسبب في تقويض الامن
والسلامه في السودان او اي شخص يعرقل
الانتقال الديمقراطي
وهو لا يتحدث عن اي شخص بعينه ولا يسمي اي
شخص بعينه لكن هذا
القرار يمكن وزير الخزانه الامريكي ووزاره
الخزنه الامريكيه بتحديد الاشخاص
المسؤولين عن
الممارسات الجاريه في السودان والتي تؤثر
على امن والسلام ولكن يعني
ما مدى تاثير هذه العقوبات والسودانيون
والسودان بشكل عام معتاد على العقوبات
الامريكيه والعقوبات الاقتصاديه والماليه
تحديدا
نعم هذا السؤال وجيه وبصراحه العقوبات
قد لا يكون لديها اثار كبير
وهذه العقوبات
ستمس المصالح الماليه والاقتصاديه اللي هو
الاشخاص داخل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وستمنعها هؤلاء الاشخاص هذا من زياره
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اذا لم يخطط
الطرفان لزياره امريكا واذا لم تكن لديهم
مصالح ماليه واقتصاديه في امريكا فهذه
العقوبات لن تجدي نفعا وانا اخمن ان
هناك عدد قليل من الاشخاص يمكن تصنيفهم
ضمن هذه الخانه يعني
اذا يعني اذا تحدثنا عن هذا الامر وربطناه
بما تقوله يعني مديره المخابرات الوطنيه
من ان القتال الوطنيه الامريكيه من ان
القتال
سيطول وقد يمتد الى دول اخرى يبدو انه رغم
التهديد بالعقوبات ليس هناك تفاؤل في
الولايات المتحده انها ستؤثر فعلا على
مجرى القتال
لا اعتقد ان هذه العقوبات من جانب
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كلها اثر لوقف
القتال الدائر في السودان اعتقد ان الامر
سيحتاج لاكثر من عقوبات امريكيه للوصول
الى الهدف
واعتقد ان هناك حاجه لجهود دول الخليج
ايضا
من اجل ان لا يكون هناك دعم لاي من اطراف
هذه الازمه دول الخليج لديها ثقل اكبر في
هذه الازمه اكثر من ذلك المتوفر للالوات
المتحده الامريكيه وللاتحاد الاوروبي ولاي
من الدول الغربيه روسيا ايضا لديها ثقل
بنظر لتواجد مجموعه التي تقدم الدعم لقوات
الدعم السريع وهذا ما استمرت روسيا في
تقديم هذا الدعم لهذه القوات فهذا سيساهم
في استمرار النزاع
السفيرشن مساعد وزير الخارجيه السابق
لشؤون افريقيا من واشنطن شكرا جزيلا لك
وفي اليوم العشرين على اندلاع المواجهات
تحتدم المعارك في الخرطوم والخرطوم بحري
والابيض ومدن اخرى بشكل تصاعدي المزيد عن
مشهد اليوم الميداني في العرض التالي
اشتباكات وصفت بالاعنف شهدتها الخرطوم في
اليوم العشرين على اندلاع القتال بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
تركزت هذه الاشتباكات في محيط القصر
الجمهوري واستخدمت فيها اسلحه ثقيله
ومتوسطه كما شن سلاح الطيران السوداني
غارات كثيفه على محيط القصر واجهتها
المضادات الجويه للدعم السريع المشهد تكرر
في الخرطوم بحري اذ شنت طائرات الجيش ايضا
غارات كثيفه على اهداف شماليه المنطقه
تصدت لها مضادات قوات الدعم السريع الجيش
السوداني قال في بيان له ان قواته اشتبكت
مع من وصفهم بالمتمردين وصدت هجومهم على
قياده منطقه بحر العسكريه وتحديدا قياده
سلاح الاشاره واستطاعت تشتيت قواتهم
وتدمير عدد من المركبات العسكريه ومصادره
عدد اخر منها من جانبها قالت قوات الدعم
السريع في بيان لها ان الجيش هاجمها في
عدد من مواقع تمركزها في العاصمه الخرطوم
بالمدفعيه والطائرات وقالت ان احياء سكنيه
تعرضت لقصف عشوائي عنيف في مسلك يشكل
تجاوزا سافرا لاعراف والقوانين الدوليه
بحسب تعبير البيان
وللاطلاع على اخر التطورات الميدانيه
تحديدا في جنوبي الخرطوم معنا من هناك
مراسل الجزيره الطاهره المرضي اليك الطاهر
واخر
المستجدات لديك
نعم اخر المستجدات ان هنالك هدوء في هذه
اللحظات في جنوب الخرطوم بعد ان كان هنالك
اشتباك في صباح الباكر وامس كانت الشبكات
عنيفه في وسط الخرطوم وفي الخرطوم البحري
وبعد بعض المناطق لم تفلح الهدنه في وقف
اصوات البنادق والانفجارات القويه التي
كان قد سمعناها سمعناها في تلك المواقع
ولكن الان هنالك هدوء في هدوء حادث في
منطقه الجنوب الخرطوم لكن هنالك اوضاع
انسانيه صعبه للغايه بسبب انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي لمده اربعه ايام او تدخل عليه
يوم الخامس وكذلك انقطاع المياه في هذه
المنطقه الماهوله بالسكان وهذا بدا يؤثر
بشكل واضح على كثير من مناحل الحياه خاصه
وان المواطنين يعتمدون على الكفرات في
تخزين الاطعمه وغيرها من الادويه بدا يؤثر
عليهم بشكل واضح كما لمسناه ذلك في جولتنا
اليوم كذلك شعرنا بان المواطن الان ايضا
يحتاج لكثير من المساعدات فيما يختص بان
الاوضاع فيما يختصب جلب المواد الغذائيه
وشرائها في انعدام السيوله النقديه التي
يمكن ان تعينه على ذلك يبدو ان الدخول هذه
الحرفي الاسبوع الثالث سيؤثر بشكل كبير
على الجانب الانساني ولذلك راينا ان عدد
من المواطنين كانوا يطالب الطرفين
بالوقف الفوري لاطلاق النار كما ان تعثر
المبادرات وان كان من الايجاد او اي جهه
اخرى في الحصول على موافقه فوريه من
الطرفين للدخول في هذه المفاوضات يعني زاد
من خيبه الامل لدى المواطنين وحتى الان
لكن هنالك انتظار لهذه الجهود وخاصه
المبادره السعوديه الامريكيه والكل يتطلع
على ان تاتي هذه ان تكون هذه المبادره هي
مبادره تستطيع ان توقف الحرب وان
الاجراءات التي اتخذها الرئيس الامريكي
فيما يختص بمحاوله الضغط على الطرفين
ينتظرون ان تكون هي اجراءات فقط للضغط
وليس للعقوبات خاصه وان الكثير من
السودانيين هنا سواء كانت احزاب او منظمات
هذه القضيه والبلي يريدون ان تحل في اطار
النقاش والحوار
شكرا لك الطاهر المرضي من جنوب الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
لا تطورات الحرفيه اوكرانيا والبدايه من
اعلان سلاح الجوي الاوكراني انه اسقط
مسيره من نوع بيرقدار في سمائك بعد ان فقد
السيطره عليها بسبب عطل فني بينما قالت
الاداره العسكريه في كياث انفجارات وحرائق
اندلعت في حي السلم يانسكي بالعاصمه جراء
سقوط حطام طائرات من دون طيار واكد رئيس
بلديه كياذا نافرق الدفاع المدني تتجه الى
حي سلم يانسكي لفحص حطام هذه المسيرات
تصور ياتي بعد وعيد روسيا صريح مفاده ان
الرد على استهداف مركز الحكم ومقر عمل
الرئيس بوتين سيكون صارما ويتزامن هذا مع
هجوم روسيا واسع على مقاطعات الجنوب
بعشرات المسيرات اعلنت كيا اسقاط عدد كبير
منها من جهتها اعلنت روسيا اسقاط مسيره
اوكرانيه حاولت استهداف مطار عسكري
بعد يوم واحد من الهجوم الذي استهدف قلعه
القرار ورمز السلطه في موسكو تمضي روسيا
في حديثها عن الرد غير عابئه بالانكار
الاوكراني تتحدث روسيا عن خيارات متعدده
للرد لا تفصح عن تفاصيلها لكنها تتواعد
بان الرد سيكون مدروسا ومتوازنا وانما
وصفته بالعقاب ات لا محاله وسيكون صارما
يصف الكرملين في بيان انكار واشنطن
مسؤوليتهما عن الهجوم بسخيف ويوزع البيان
المهام حيث اتهم واشنطن بالتخطيط للعمليه
في حين قال ان مهمتكيف كانت التنفيذ فقط
اتهامات رد عليها منسق الاتصالات بمجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي حيث قال جون كاربي
ان واشنطن لا تشجع اوكرانيا ولا تمكنها من
المعدات التي تسمح لها بتوجيه ضربات خارج
اراضيها وقال ان المزاعم الروسيه كاذبه
اما اوكرانيا التي نفت بدورها علاقتها
بالهجوم فاكدت ان اولوياتها تحرير اراضيها
وليس الهجوم على موسكو وتحدث رئيسها
في زيارته عن الاف الجرائم التي قال ان
روسيا ارتكبتها في شهر واحد
اما على الجبهات فيوميات الحرب تكتب
باستمرار دون تسجيل الغلبه لاي من
الفريقين حتى الان ما تزال باخمت محور
الصراع منذ اشهر عصيه على الروس لاشهر
متتاليه رغم تقدمهم في محاور عده وسط تمسك
الجيش الاوكراني بمواقعه غرب المدينه
ويتحدث الجيش الاوكراني عن اسقاط 18 طائره
مسيره ايرانيه من طراز شاهد من اصل 24
اطلقتها القوات الروسيه من بحر ازوف جنوبا
باتجاه مدن الجنوب والعاصمه وفي المنطقه
الحدوديه قال حاكم مقاطعه الروسيه ان
الدفاعات الجويه اسقطت مسيره اوكرانيه
كانت تعتزم مهاجمه المقاطعه وفيزا بروجيا
تتحدث المصادر العسكريه الروسيه عن
استهداف مخازن ذخيره وتجمع لاليات الجيش
الاوكراني كما استهدف الروس ايضا مستودعا
اوكرانيا اخر للذخيره قرب مدينه بيرسلاف
في مقاطعه خرسون خرسون التي تحاول ان
تلملم جراحها بعد قصف روسي اسفر عن مقتل
50 شخصا ويسارع سكانها الخطى لجمع المؤونه
وتخزينها تحسبا لهجوم روسي يقولون انه
وشيك وعنيف
معنى من موسكو العقيد فيكتور
محرر اشؤون العسكريه في وكاله التاسع
الروسيه ومنكيات بترو بيركوسكي الباحث
والمحلل السياسي سابدا مع ضيفي من روسيا
العقيد فيكتور
سيد فيكتور هل الهجوم بالمسيرات
بهذا الشكل على كييف وعلى مناطق اخرى بشكل
مكثف وبدايه ما تعتبره روسيا الرد على
الهجوم على
ان هذه الهجمات ليست رعد لان
الطائرات المسيره التي هاجمت كيف هي
بيركتار بيركتار هي اسلحه موجوده لدى
الاوكرانيين عدا عن ذلك الرد الروسي لن
يكون بالمسيرات بل سيكون بالصواريخ لذلك
ان نقول ان موسكو تتعامل بهذه الامور
البسيطه وبهجمات بسيطه على
كيف ان روسيا لا تمارس السرك العسكري
هي طائره واحده وتحدثت عنها الاوكرانيه
بانها فقدت السيطره عليها فاسقطتها ليس عن
هذه الطائره نتحدث نتحدث عنها جماعه اخرى
بطائرات مسيره استهدفت العديد من المناطق
بعضها في مقاطعه كييف
المسيرات الاخرى الانتحاريه السيارات
الانتحاريه مثل
جيران او غيرها قد يكون هذا سليم ولكن
المسيره التي اسقطوها الاوكرانيين كانت
دار
اذا ليس هذا هو الرد وما زالت غياب تنتظر
ردا مشابها اذا صح التعبير
شكرا لكم على هذا السؤال في الواقع روسيا
تهاجم
كيف في بدايه الشهر واليوم ايضا
وسمعت ان في مناطق قريبه من مسكني كان
هناك
صفارات الانذار تقوم روسيا
بالهجوم على كيف قبل وبعد هذه الهجمات
المفتعله في الكريمل
وقامت
بقصف خرسون
الذي
لا تزال تسميه منطقه روسيه وفي نتيجه هذا
القصف قتل ما يزيد عن 20 شخص وكان هناك
اربعين جريح اذا روسيا تستمر في
استراتيجيه
تدمير
المدنيين ومن المعروف ان
قوات الدفاع الجويه اذا تحدثنا عن اخر
هجمات بالامس واليوم تدمر 90% من المسيرات
الايرانيه الموجوده لدى الروس
يعني ما زالت روسيا تتهم اوكرانيا وتتهم
ايضا الولايات المتحده بالهجوم على
الكريملين لكن لماذا على العالم ان يصدق
ان هذا الهجوم هدفه اغتيال بوتين هل يمكن
لطائره من هذا النوع في مكان متسع من عده
ابنيه يكون شخص موجود في في الداخل غير
معروف اين يكون موجود يعني هل يمكن لطائره
بهذا الحجم وبهذه الصغر ان تغتال شخصا في
الداخل يعني على العالم ان يصدق هذه
الروايه
في الواقع ان هذه المسيرات هاجمت الكرملين
والموقع الذي يقع به الرئيس هل ممكن ان
تقتله املاك هذا سؤال اخر
هذه
المسيرات انطلقت من مواقع في موسكو من قبل
جماعات تابعه للمتعصبين الاوكرانيين
تماما كما ان البراكتار فيكي ليس الرومان
ارسلوه هناك الكثير من ادعيه التي تنتشر
في كييف يقولون الروس ان يقول الاوكرانيين
انهم هم من صنعوا البحر الاسود
وانهم هم دمروا الاسطول البحري ولكن
هذا كلام ما لا يصدقه احد اما كون
اوكرانيا ارادت ان تقوم بضرب الكريم
الكرملين هذا ما يعلنه جميع السياسيين
الاوكرانيين بما فيه
استشاري وزير الامن
والمخابرات المخابرات
اوكرانيا ايضا تقول انها تريد ان تنتقم من
الكرملين
فاوكرانيا تفجر سكك الحديد في برانسك
واوكرانيا حاولت قتل
اداريين في القرب وممكن ان اذكر عدد كبير
من الهجمات الارهابيه التي نظمتها
اوكرانيا لذلك
كل هذه الاخطاء التي
يحدثون عنها من اوكرانيا شيء مثير
للاهتمام ولكنه ليس حقيقي يتحدث
بالاوكرانيا ما ردك سيد بيتر على
هذه
يعني ما يستشهد به ضيفنا من موسكو ليؤكد
ان
اوكرانيا هي من ارسلت الطائره ولو انها من
داخل الاراضي الروسيه
يعلمون
ان الرئيس الروسي ضد يحب ان يقول دائما
اننا لو اردنا قتل احد لقمنا بهذا لذلك في
هذه الحاله اذا كانت
المخابرات
الاوكرانيه التي دمرت الجسر القرمي
ودمرت وقسمت مواقع استراتيجيه كالمطارات
العسكريه الروسيه ودمرت الطائرات تستطيع
حمل صواريخ نوويه بعد كل هذه العمليات لو
كانت المخابرات تريد ان تقتل بوتين قامت
بهذا لن ينقذ بوتين من مثل هذه العمليات
لا
ملجا ولا شيء اخر
الشيء الثاني هذا العمل المزيف قضيه
الهجوم على كريم في الواقع لم تؤذي هذه
العمليه للكرملين ولا بوتين ولم يكن بوتين
موجود هناك ولكن من جانب اخر
قبل هذا العيد القادم والمهم لروسيا بوتين
يريد ان يظهر
اظهروا انظروا انا ايضا مهدد مثل الشعب
انه يريد ان ينظر كشخص مشترك في هذه الحرب
والذي تهدده هذه الحرب كاي جندي عادي اي
انه يتظاهر انه جندي للشعب حتى يزيد من
شعبيته وسط الشعب الشعبيه التي سقطت
الشيء الثاني روسيا فعلا
دمرت خطوط الغاز
الشماليه في العام الماضي حتى ترفع اسعار
الغاز للاوروبيين وحتى تجمد اوروبا من
البرد وحتى تجبر اوروبا عن على ترك دعم
اوكرانيا والان روسيا تهدد اوكرانيا او
تتهم عفوا اوكرانيا انها دوله ارهابيه حتى
لا تقوم الدول الغربيه بمد اوكرانيا
بطائرات اف 16 ويجب ان اقول هنا ان هذا
هذه الخطه لن تعمل لان اليوم
رئيس الوزراء الهولندي الذي الدوله التي
تعتبر دوله اوروبيه حذره جدا قال انه ليس
هناك اي شيء ممنوع في مد اوكرانيا
السياسي شكرا جزيلا لك وشكرا للعقيد
فيكتور من موسكو محرر الشؤون العسكريه في
وكاله تاس الروسيه
جددت الخارجيه القطريه دعوتها الى حل
الازمه الروسيه الاوكرانيه عبر الحوار
والطرق الدبلوماسيه وعدم اتخاذما من شانه
ان يؤدي الى مزيد من التصعيد وقالت ان
الاجراءات التصعيديه مثل الاستهداف مبنى
الكرملين سينتج عنها تصاعد العنف واطاله
امد الازمه واتساع مداها كما حذرت من
التبعات الخطيره لهذه الاعمال العدائيه
على جهود حل الازمه سلميا وشددت على انها
تدعم الجهود الدوليه لايجاد حل سلمى
للازمه
[موسيقى]
شيع الاف الفلسطينيين جافاميين ثلاثه
شهداء اغتالتهم قوات الاحتلال في البلده
القديمه في مدينه نابلس وفي وقت قل فيه
الجيش الاسرائيلي انه قتل ناشطين في نابلس
نفدا عمليه في الاغوار الشهر الماضي تبنت
حماس عمليه الاغوار وقالت انها جاءت ردا
على الاعتداءات في الاقصى خلال رمضان كما
قتلت قوه الاحتلال شابه ايمان عوده في
حواره بذريعه تنفيذ عمليه الطعن
بلباس نساء وع
مال من المستعربين البلده القديمه في
مدينه نابلس
تلاها رطل من الاليات العسكريه التي
اقتحمت المدينه
قتل نيران وقنابل الغاز باتجاه الطلبه
القوات الاسرائيليه حاصرت اما منزلا داخل
حاره الياسمين
واستخدمت صواريخ ورصاصا متفجرا
بعد رفض المقاومين الاستسلام
الاعداد الكبيره للجنود الاحتلال شفناها
كانت معبيه الحاره
وماخذين نقاط بجميع الدور اللي حوالين
الحاره طبعا عشان هذا اسلوبهم لا يعرفوا
ما حداش يقدر يخرج من الحاره
وصوتي التفجيرات بشكل مش طبيعي يعني مهمهم
انه في صغار في مرضعه في في حريم فش عندهم
حرمات
معاذ مصري وحسن قطناني وابراهيم جوري صاحب
المنزل اغتالتهم قوات الاحتلال بعد شهر من
تنفيذ عمليه في الاغوار ادت الى مقتل ثلاث
مستوطنات
تشييع الشهداء شارك فيه الاف الفلسطينيين
تقدمهم عشرات المقاومين من الفصائل كافه
كتائب القسام الجناح المسلح لحركه حماس
نعت الشهداء وقالت ان العمليه نفذت في
الاغوار ردا على تدنيس المسجد الاقصى
واستهداف المعتكفات في شهر رمضان
الرئاسه الفلسطينيه حملت الاحتلال
التداعيات عمليه الاغتيال بينما توعدت
الفصائل بالانتقام عمليه الاغتيال تاتي في
ظل التهديدات الاسرائيليه بتوسيع العمليات
العسكريه في شمال الضفه الغربيه والتي لا
يستثنى منها الاسرى وهذه المشاهد لحجم
الدمار والاعلان الفوري عن تفاصيل العمليه
تبدو وفق مراقبين الرساله لارضاء منتقدي
حكومتي بنيامين نتنياهو
فحجم الدمار الذي ظهر بعد تنفيذ العمليه
اشار وفق مراقبينا الى انها توجه رساله
للداخل الاسرائيلي في محاوله لكسر اراده
الشعب الفلسطيني على المقاومه واستعاده
هيبه الردع الاسرائيليه التي تضررت كثيرا
في الاشهر الاخيره لذلك علينا ان نستعد
لمعركه كبيره
لكن نهار محافظه نابلس لم ينتهي فجنود
الاحتلال قتلوا الشابه ايمان عوده في بلده
حواره الجنوبيه المحافظه حيث زعم الاحتلال
انها حاولت طعن جندي بينما فند
الفلسطينيون هذه الروايه جيفا الجزيره
نابلس
وانا من رام الله دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي
الامين العام للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
دكتور مصطفى مرحبا بك لم يتغير شيء في
سلوك قوات الاحتلال رغم كل الاتصالات
والاجتماعات وحتى رغم كل الردود
الفلسطينيه ايضا
قوات الاحتلال وحكومه نتنياهو الفاشيه
تريد شيئا واحدا
في كل العمليات التي تنفذها تريد ان تكسر
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وتوقفها الهدف
المركزي الرئيسي لهذه الحكومه الاسرائيليه
ان تواصل عمليه الضم والتهويد للضفه
الغربيه بكاملها وطبعا للقدس وللمقدسات
الدينيه دون ان تكون هناك مقاومه فلسطينيه
ولكنها تفشل تفشل المرات والاخرى اليوم
قاموا باغتيال ثلاثه من المناضلين البواسل
وقاموا بقتل وحشي للشابه ايمان عوده
وتركوا اطفالها ايتاما ولكن هذا كله يعبر
عن فشل وليس عن نجاح مقابل ومكان كل مقاوم
فلسطيني يستشهد ياتي مئه مقاومه اخر عمليا
الشعب الفلسطيني وصل الى قناعه عميقه اولا
ان هؤلاء على مفاوضات لا قيمه له عديم
الفائده ثانيا ان احدا لن يساعدنا ما لم
نساعد انفسنا وعلينا الاعتماد على النفس
وثالثا ان اسرائيل لا تفهم الا لغه والحل
الوحيد هو تصعيد المقاومه الفلسطينيه طيب
اذا كان الامر كذلك هل تبدو الاوضاع مرشحه
للتصعيد للتصعيد على مستوى اوسع وفي اكثر
من منطقه يعني لا تبقى منحصره مثلا في
مناطق في الضفه الغربيه او على مستوى
صواريخ من القطاع وغارات اسرائيليه في
اماكن هل يمكن ان نشهد المعركه الكبرى كما
يتوقع البعض
يمكن جدا ولكن ليس بالضروره فورا وليس
بالضروره غدا لكن انا برايي الوضع في
الضفه الغربيه وفي قطاع غزه من فلسطين في
فلسطين عموما بما في ذلك في الداخل
الفلسطيني مرشح للتحول الى انتفاضه شعبيه
شامله وواسعه وهذا طبعا نتيجه الممارسات
والقمع الاسرائيلي والاهم من ذلك نتيجه
الاحساس بان اسرائيل تريد هدوء بمعنى وقف
المقاومه في ظل استمرارها في الضم
والتهويد والمجتمع الدولي يسكت عليها
بالتالي نعم قد تتجه الامور الى انفجار
شامل يؤدي يؤدي لاحقا الى طبعا دخول جبهات
اخرى على الساحه هذا محتمل جدا ويمكن ان
يتطور في ساعات اذا وصل الاحتلال هذه
الاعتداءات الهمجيه طيب يبقى سؤال متعلق
يعني قد يكون سؤالنا امنيا ان اسرائيل
كانت تعرف مكان وجود هذين شابين
وتتعقبهما وتمكنت من الدخول
قتلهما ولو بفرقه من المستعربين لكن امنيا
ماذا يعني ذلك
اولا اسرائيل لم تعرف مكان وجود هذين
والدليل على ذلك انها وصلت طوال الشهر
الماضي اكثر من شهر عمليات المداهمه في
منطقه اريحا وطبعا محاولات للوصول الى
معلومات في نابلس وجنين لم تستطع ان تحدد
مكانهما حتى صباح اليوم كما قالت وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه فقط صباح اليوم عرفوا
اين موجودين هؤلاء المناضلين الذين نفذوا
طبعا العمليه المعروفه
ولجوا الى نابلس لكن طبعا لدى اسرائيل
وسائل التجسس خطيره وكثيره وتقنيه كبيره
تتجسس على الهواتف لديها طائرات مسيره
صغيره جدا يمكن ان تدخل حتى الى غرف
البيوت وبالتالي ليس غريبا ان تصل في
النتيجه الى معلومات عن بعض المناضلين
وطبعا نحن لا ننفي وجود عنصر بشري هنا
وهذا امر ما يجب فحصه ولكن بصوره عامه
الاحتلال يعتبر نفسه فاشلا
لانه طوال شهر كامل لم يستطع ان يحدد مكان
هؤلاء المناضلين وحتى الان هو عاجز عن
تصفيه هذه المقاومه الجاريه في مناطق
مختلفه شكرا لك الامين العام للمبادره
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه الدكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي كنت معنا من رام الله
قالت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه ان تحقيقا
داخليا اعده سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي كشف عن
وجود خلل في تفعيل منظومه القبه الحديديه
ونقلت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي ان الخلل
التقني حاله دون اعتراض صواريخ عديده
اطلقتها المقاومه الفلسطينيه باتجاه مدينه
سبيروت بعد ظهر يوم الثلاثاء الماضي
[موسيقى]
سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي يكشف عن خلل في
تفعيل منظومه القبه الحديديه في جوله
القتال الاخيره مع المقاومه الفلسطينيه
وبحسب اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي فان خللا
تقنيا حالا اعتراض صواريخ عده اطلقت
باتجاه مدينه سديرات مطلع هذا الاسبوع
فكيف يبدو اداء المنظومه ميدانيه
تقول اسرائيل ان المنظومه قادره على
اعتراض 95% من الصواريخ وتضيف ان المنظومه
نجحت في اعتراض ما لا يقل عن 90% من
الاهداف خلال الجوله الاخيره
وبحسب معلومات الجيش الاسرائيلي فان القبه
الحديديه اعترضت في عمليه سيف القدس
661 صاروخا من اصل ثلاثه
الاف3300 صاروخ و
735 صاروخا من اصل اربعه الاف وخمسمائه
واربعه وتسعين صاروخا
و428 صاروخا اطلق من قطاع غزه من اصل 1500
صاروخ في عمليه حجاره السجين
لكن العوده الى دعاوى التعويض التي قدمت
خلال العمليات العسكريه تعطي نظره اقرب
الى فاعليه القبه الحديديه مع نهايه عمليه
سيف القدس في مايو ايار عام 2021
يتضح ان الاسرائيليين في المناطق
المستهدفه بصواريخ المقاومه تقدموا بنحو
خمسه الاف وثمانمائه وثلاثين دعوه تعويض
عن الخسائر الماديه التي اصابت ممتلكاتهم
منها اكثر من ثلاثه
الاف3300 دعوه اضرار في المباني وما يزيد
على 2200 دعوه اضرار في السيارات وقرابه
170 دعوه اضرار اخرى لتبلغ قيمه الاضرار
بالممتلكات نحو 55 مليون دولار هذا عدا عن
الخسائر الاقتصاديه الاخرى نشر نظام القبه
الحديديه للمره الاولى نهايه 2011
يديرها سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي نشرت بدايه
بالقرب من قطاع غزه وتوسع الدائرتها لاحقا
لتشمل نشرب بطاريات قرب عسقلان واشدود
وجنوب تل ابيب ومدينه تيفود الواقعه على
مسافه 20 كيلومترا من حدود غزه وتبلغ قيمه
صاروخ تنير الواحد المستخدم في عمليه
الاعتراض نحو 50 الف دولار
[موسيقى]
في اخبار العلم الاخرى افدى رئيس جبهه
الخلاص الوطني احمد نجيب الشابي انه تلقى
اخطارا من قد التحقيق بمثوله امام القضاء
الى جانب عدد من المحامين وثلاث وعشرين
شخصيه سيتم التحقيق معها من جهتها اعلان
المحامي العياشي الهمامي ان تحقيق سيتم في
التهم نفسها المتعلقه بالتامر على امن
الدوله والتي وجهت سابقا لعدد من
السياسيين والنشاطات واقل الهمامي انما
سماه التعامل البوليسي من طرف قيس سعيد
وسلطته متواصل ورقعه القمع متواصله حسب
تعبيره
شخصيا اتوقع باننا نتعرف الى خطر الايقاف
ولذلك عوض ان ننتظر ان ينزل علينا هذا
العقاب وندافع عن انفسنا اراد اردنا ان
نستبرقه وان نعلمكم والراي العام بحقيقه
ما يجب هذه النقطه الاولى النقطه الثانيه
موقفي الشخصي لن اتعاون مع القاتل القضيه
لا شيء فيها يفيد وجود مؤامره في حق ايا
كان معركتنا هي مع مثير الدعوه قيس سعيد
والسلطه التنفيذيه
ومجالها ليس القضاء وانما مجالها المعترك
السياسي
وصف رئيس رابطه التونسيه للدفاع عن حقوق
الانسان بسام الطريفي في تصريح لاذاعه
محليه ووصف الوضع الحقوقيه في تونس
بالمقلق والخطير فيما يتعلق بالحريات
العامه والفرديه من جهه ثانيه اشاره طريفي
الى ان مبادره الحوار التي اعدتها
المنظمات المدنيه ومن بينها رابطه حقوق
الانسان جاهزه وفي انتظار الظرف المناسب
لاعلانها
تنقيط بعض التشريعات الاربع وخمسين نحن
طلبنا بالغائه الانتخابات 55 مرسوم 55
تنقيته كذلك وتركيز هيئه مستقل هيئه
مستقله المحكمه الدستوريه اليوم منجموش
نكمل ونواصلوا في هذا المسار بدون
محكمه دستوريه
نمشي الى تنقيط المناخ واللي قاعدين نشوفو
فيه من انتهاكات وضرب لحريه الاعلام
والصحافه وحريه تعبير
اعلنا برنامج الاغذيه العالميه التابع
للامم المتحده وقفه توزيع المواد الغذائيه
في اقليم تيجراي شماليه اثيوبيا واوضح
بيان البرنامج ان سبب وقف عمليه التوزيع
يعود الى تقارير تفيد بتحويل مسار
المساعدات مضح ان توزيع المساعدات لن
يستانف قبل ضمان الوصولها الى مستحقيها
اعلنت وزاره الصحه المصريه مصرع 17 شخصا
واصابه 29 في حدث مروري على طريق الخارجه
اسيوط جنوبيه البلاد ودفعت الوزاره 26
سياره اسعاف الى موقع الحادث لنجده
المصابين ووجه وزير الصحه المصريه برفع
حاله الاستعداد في مستشفيات محافظه اسيوط
والمحافظات المجاوره وتوفير المستلزمات
الطبيه لاسعاف الجرحى
اعلنت وزاره البترول والثروه المعدنيه
المصريه انها قررت زياده سعر بيع السولار
محليا نتيجه لارتفاع الاسعار العالميه
للمنتجات البتروليه واسعار صرف الدولار
امام الجنيه المصري وقررت لجنه تسعير
التلقائيه رفع اسعار السولار بمقدار جنيه
الى 8 جنيهات وربع اي ما يعادل 27 سنتا
لللتر لكن اللجنه ابقت على اسعار البنزين
دون تغيير